ALEX DANILO: It's
nice to be in Beijing.
Lovely to see you
all here today.
That's gone out of-- oh,
excuse me, one moment.
Right, OK, hi, my
name is Alex Danilo.
I've been doing web standards
with the W3C since 2002,
so, almost 15 years now.
I'm currently editing the
HTML 5.2 specification.
I've done a lot of work with
SVG and I'm playing around
with WebAssembly, which is a
really exciting new technology.
But today I want to talk to
you about HTTPS, which is also
a very important technology when
you're building progressive web
apps.
So one thing that we say when
you're building progressive web
apps is that they introduce
a whole lot of new APIs.
And these new APIs are
extremely powerful.
So with that new power
comes great responsibility.
It is your job to
protect your users
and protect your own sites
from any kinds of problems.
And I'll try to
explain what I mean.
So even older APIs, like
geolocation, geolocation
used to be available on HTTP.
And now it is moving to HTTPS,
because knowing where a user is
a very powerful thing.
For example, if you use
geolocation on your site,
you know if your user is at home
or at work, or almost anywhere.
And that is a lot of knowledge
that you have about the users.
So this is why it's important to
take care of that information.
So I'll tell you a little story.
And this is the
story of the web.
Imagine 25 years ago,
a little scientist
decided that he wanted
to share his documents
with his fellow colleagues.
And so I wrote a little
server and a little browser.
And you could send these
documents to each other.
So I could send you my
document of my latest
scientific discovery.
This was a fantastic idea.
And when I built that, if I was
that man 25 years ago building
that, I wouldn't
care about HTTPS.
I would just use
the normal network
and come up with a simple
protocol, something
I would call HTTP.
And I would invent
a language called
HTML to display the documents.
And my name is Tim Berners-Lee.
That is actually what happened.
But that was 25 years ago.
And since then, the
web has changed.
It's moved from a document
format to something
we can build full, rich apps.
And so in the old days, it was
fine to just go and collect
a document from the
server and retrieve it,
because all the network was
inside a very closed system.
But fast-forward to today,
and all that traffic
travels around the
world, between countries
all over the place.
And the fact is that
anybody on the network,
between you and the server, can
see that traffic coming past.
Now when we're sharing
documents, that was OK.
But today, a lot of the internet
is about e-commerce and money.
So it's your
responsibility to protect
your revenue streams
as website developers,
and also your users'
credit card information.
If I'm on public
Wi-Fi, or connecting
to my internet service provider,
if I send my credit card
number, over HTTP, anybody
in between can see it.
And this is a real problem.
So this is what we
need to protect.
We need to protect the financial
backbone of web commerce.
And this is why
HTTPS is crucial.
So what we're
really aiming to do
is to try and get this little
green icon up on our sites.
And to get that to happen, there
are three fundamental things
that you need to do.
Now, I'll just
quickly explain what
happens if you don't do this.
If this was google.com and
it was served over HTTP,
I could be sitting in
an airport connected
to a public Wi-Fi
spot, and somebody
could put a big
advertisement right here
on top of my page saying, click
here, download the new Chrome
browser.
And if I click that, it
could take me to a site
that downloads malware
onto my laptop.
And this is the risk with HTTP.
But with HTTPS, this
does not happen.
And there are three
things that it gives you.
The first thing it
gives you is identity.
Right?
With HTTPS, what happens
is a digital certificate
is sent between the
server and the client.
What that certificate
does is it guarantees
that if I connect to
google.com or google.cn,
I am talking to that server
and not another server that
is impersonating that site.
So it's very important.
So it guarantees you are
connecting to the server you
attempted to connect to.
The second thing it gives
you is confidentiality.
What that means
is nobody can read
the data transferred between
the server and the browser.
So in the case where we were
exchanging credit card numbers,
no one can see my
credit card number
and then use it to
buy things on Alibaba.
This is very important.
And the third thing it gives
me is integrity of data.
And what that means
is [AUDIO OUT]
modified the data between
the server and the browser.
So the only two
parties that can change
the data that we
exchange are the server
and the browser itself.
So these are three fundamental
pieces that you get with HTTPS.
OK, but a lot of people
wondered about the performance
impact, the cost of
actually implementing HTTPS,
and the maintenance burden.
Now of course, as
developers, if you're
building sites or serving
sites, you want it to be fast,
so you worry about performance.
You don't want to
spend a lot of money,
or you don't want to
burn money for no reason.
So cost is important.
And maintenance is [AUDIO OUT].
It means you have to
get the certificates.
You have to manage them.
You have to work with them.
So let's just dive into
this a little bit more.
So let's take a look at
a few of the criticisms
that people have
levied against HTTPS.
One is that my site
doesn't really need it.
Do you really need it?
I mean, all my site does
is show a few photos
that I've taken on my holidays.
Is that really
necessary to use it?
The other thing is, it'll
cause performance problems.
And I'll lose money, because
if my site slows down,
people will run away and they
won't buy the e-commerce things
that I have for sale.
The other thing is, it
costs a lot to implement.
And third party sites won't
necessarily support it.
So why should I bother?
So let's just dive
into them one by one.
What we think is that HTTPS
is the minimum foundation
of building a modern website
today, or a modern web app--
something you really need to do.
Because even if you think
your site doesn't need it,
if you go, as I said before,
to a public Wi-Fi hotspot
and connect to your simple
site that just shows pictures,
there is nothing stopping
that site popping up
an ad over the top of the
picture saying, click me.
I personally have connected HTTP
sites on my phone at airports
and suddenly I have
a pop-up that says,
your Android device is
infected with malware.
Click here to wipe your device.
Has anyone experienced anything
like that in this room?
Yes, yes, a few people.
Right, so that is
the risk using HTTP.
So one of the other seriously
important aspects of this
is all of these
fantastic new APIs
that give you the progressive
web app experience.
Not even just progressive web
apps, but any modern site,
these require HTTPS.
Not all of them here
now, but some people
may still use app cache and
encrypted media extensions.
Now, both of those APIs
currently work without HTTPS,
but they are being migrated
to HTTPS as an extra security
measure because app cache
is a perfect example where
I can intercept the traffic
and store the wrong data
into my app cache.
So that is moving to HTTPS.
Same with encrypted
media extensions.
So if you currently
use these two APIs,
please make a migration plan and
move off HTTP and onto HTTPS.
OK.
We've just heard Pete give us
a lovely explanation about what
service workers are and why
they are so useful to you.
Now, the thing is that
service workers will only
work on an HTTPS connection.
You must have HTTPS or service
worker will fail to run at all.
Now the reason for this
is that the service worker
is the thing that jumps between
the browser and the network.
So it has a massive,
massive exposure
to the data that comes between
the browser and the server.
So it must be encrypted.
This is purely for protection
of your users, of course.
So now, what do we say here?
So the point about
this slide is basically
HTTPS is no longer considered
something that is only needed
for security-sensitive sites.
We're seeing ad injections,
all sorts of strange things
that go on in the
public internet.
And it's very important
for your users
to give them a proper
user experience.
Because if you're running
an e-commerce site,
you want all the
money to come to you.
If you're hosting some
kind of information
and you use advertising
to monetize that,
you don't want your
users to suddenly
be served different ads and
the money to go somebody else.
So what about the
performance issues?
One of the things that
people talk about is it'll
cause performance problems
and I'll lose money.
So, this might have been
true five to 10 years ago.
But all the browser vendors
and the entire internet
infrastructure has
changed over the years.
And it's no longer
a real problem.
So I'll tell you what's
happened in the past few years.
So when you set up a HTTPS
session, what happens
is that normally
you connect on HTTP.
Say if your server is serving
HTTPS only and somebody
attempts to connect
with an HTTP address,
there were three round trips.
What happens is that
you connect with HTTP.
The server says, sorry,
here's a 301 redirect.
We actually want you
to serve over HTTPS.
And then you have
to go back and forth
to the server two more times
to do a TLS handshake to set up
the HTTPS session.
You can shorten that very
easily by using Strict Transport
Security, HSTS.
And so what this is is
a header that you return
from your server to the browser
that says, in the future,
if you ever ask for
HTTP, we will just
please ask for HTTPS instead.
So in this example, I'm
saying, for the next month,
if anybody types
HTTP into my domain,
automatically issue an
HTTPS attempt to connect.
Right, so if I have
http://google.cn,
and this comes back in the first
response, then in the future,
if the user types
http://google.cn
into the browser
and hits Return,
the browser will
intercept and go,
no, it should be HTTPS,
and start the TLS handshake
immediately, which
saves a full round trip.
So this is basically,
that's the written version.
If you didn't understand how
I was speaking because I do
have an Australian accent, which
can be difficult to understand,
even for me.
OK, so, oh [INAUDIBLE].
This keeps jumping out of--
sorry, yeah.
OK, so here is a
typical handshake.
So this is what I was
talking about before.
The original HTTP
request goes out.
The 301 redirect comes back.
Then we start doing
the TLS handshake.
So there are three
full round trips
until we can issue
the first get requests
to get our first resource.
So it's a lot of slowdown.
But there are ways
to speed this up.
This is the actual
TLS handshake itself.
And so one of the
things that you see here
is that it goes out, comes
back with a certificate,
says, OK, it's finished, waits
for the response, and then
issues the get request.
But what we can actually
do on the client side
is change the order by
issuing the get request
before the second or the
third finished has come back.
And so this will actually
speed up our response time.
And we call this
TLS false start.
So we're actually
starting to get requests
before we've acknowledged that
we're finished the hand shake.
And that is an option that you
can turn on on your server.
And I encourage you to do so.
Now another thing is that
when we start the first TLS
handshake, we can
use a session ID.
So this session ID is
something we can issue.
So with the first request
to set up the TLS handshake,
we send a session ID.
And what that does is
that in the future when
we start to do another
request, we can actually
use what is called TLS session
resumption, which will also
get rid of the extra
finished, takes off
one of the round trips.
So that also speeds things up.
This is also something you
should turn on on your servers.
OK, now another
incredibly important thing
is that HTTPS is
required for HTTP/2.
Does anybody know what
HTTP/2 is, in the room?
A few people, great.
Well, HTTP2 is the
next generation
of transport protocol
for web browsers.
And two of its main features are
multiplexing and server push.
Multiplexing means that
you can get multiple assets
on a single TCP IP connection.
So instead of using one
socket for one resource
at the same time, I can be
fetching three, or four, or 10,
or 100 resources on
the one TCP connection.
And the browser and the server
negotiate how that works.
Server push is a
completely different thing.
Server push means
that the server
can send assets to the browser
before the browser asks
for them.
So for example, if I ask
for an HTML page that
contains a lot of
images, the server
can start sending
the HTML page back.
And the server knows that
the next thing I will do
is ask for all the
images on the page.
So the server can begin sending
the images back to the browser
even before I ask for them.
And this is a feature of HTTP/2.
And the reason it's there is to
speed up loading of websites.
However HTTP/2 requires HTTPS.
So it runs on top of HTTPS.
One of the reasons
that is is that there
is a lot of
infrastructure already
around the world for the web.
There are a lot of
gateways that all
understand HTTP 1.0 and 1.1.
All of those gateways can
do things with the traffic.
Right?
They could change things.
They could do
compression on the fly.
They can make all sorts
of different changes.
And because of the
existing infrastructure,
its impossible to deploy
HTTP/2 without sending it
over HTTPS, which provides
an end to end connection
with no integrity violation.
Remember, we talked
about integrity?
So HTTPS means the server
data is exactly what ends up
at the client.
And that's why HTTPS
needs to be the transport
medium for HTTP/2.
OK, so here is an
example of a site
called weather.com, who
actually made the transition
from an HTTP site to an
HTTPS site and HTTP/2
at the same time.
Due to their architecture when
they first jumped to HTTPS,
they saw a 50-millisecond
slowdown because of the way
their site was constructed.
However, this was part of a
larger plan to shift to HTTP/2.
And when they deployed
the HTTP/2 version,
they saw a
250-millisecond-per-page-view
reduction in time, in latency.
So they saved a quarter
of a second on a page
by switching to an
HTTPS connection
with HTTP/2 traffic
on top of it.
So from a performance
point of view,
you can actually
get a win if you
shift to this kind of model.
OK, but what about the expense?
I mean, what happens
with the HTTPS connection
is that the server
and the client
communicate using
digital certificates.
And you have to
obtain a certificate.
And historically, this has
been a very expensive thing.
And so people don't
want to spend the money
to do this kind of thing,
all the cost of implementing,
developer time, et cetera.
So buying a cost, buying
a certificate was costly.
The other concern with
HTTPS that I've heard
is search ranking.
So if you tell a
search engine, I
have an HTTP version of my
site and an HTTPS version
of my site, people
sometimes think
that means because half your
traffic is going to each site
that your search
ranking will drop.
This is not quite true.
And I'll just walk you
through a couple of things.
So let's start
with certificates.
Has anyone bought a
certificate for HTTPS recently?
At least a couple of people.
OK, well, we've known
for this project that's
an external project over,
I'm not exactly sure
where it's hosted, but they sell
certificates for $16 a year.
16 US dollars, that's
about 110 yuan.
So that's not a lot of money.
In fact, if you host
a multi-site site,
they'll sell it
for about 170 yuan.
So it's not actually
a large expense
when you're paying
developers to write code.
Then there's another project
that started relatively
recently, called Let's Encrypt.
And this project provides
you certificates for free.
So they don't cost you anything.
Now this is a great way to avoid
having to spend money on this.
And so that really takes
away any problem of cost.
Now, we should go into
the search ranking.
Now search ranking is
an interesting one.
You, of course, don't want
to go down in search ranking.
Everybody's trying to get up
to the top as much as possible.
So if you migrate your
site from HTTP to HTTPS,
there are a few best
practices that you
can use that search
engines will understand.
So one of the first things is if
you issue this HTTP 301 direct,
like say, somebody says,
HTTP, go and get the services,
no, 301 redirect.
If you actually put in moved
permanently the new location,
then from that point
on, the browser
knows, for the meantime,
that it should go there.
But search engines are smart
enough to remember these too.
So search engines
will go, ah, the HTTP
site is no longer there.
We will refer to the HTTPS
site as the correct site.
And then on top of that,
inside your content,
when you serve it on HTTPS,
you need to put in this,
link rel=canonical.
Now this tells the
search engine that this
is the definitive
version of your site.
Right, so the HTTPS
version is canonical,
which means whenever you want
to refer to that for search
ranking or anything like
that, that is the site and not
the HTTP.
OK, so as far as
working out what
to do with search
engine stuff, we've
put together a whole
lot of guidance.
So if you actually go to the
site, you can walk through it
and find a whole lot of
guidance on best practices
to make sure that your search
engine ranking remains high
when you make the migration
from HTTP to HTTPS.
It's a very good thing to do.
OK so finally, the last
point on all of this
is that if you have a
site that pulls together
content from a bunch of
third party sites, like ads,
or images from any image
server, or content from a CDN,
then you have to worry about
whether or not those sites
support HTTPS as well.
Because to get the
full green icon,
all your content on the page
needs to be served on HTTPS.
Now one of the most
important things that we
put on our websites are ads.
And so of course, there was this
kind of survey done by the IAB.
The IAB is a internet
advertising kind
of oversight committee that
has a lot of the ad serving
networks as members.
So, back as far back as
2013, so three years ago,
they noted that a lot
of their members, 80%,
had already completely
shifted to HTTPS.
And the plan was to have
100% compliance very soon.
So as far as ad serving goes,
that's already well and truly
on this way.
And we'll wait to see when
they finally hit 100%.
Now if you are a developer
and you're working with HTTPS
and you're trying to
debug on your site,
you can also pull
up Chrome DevTools.
So Pete showed you
Chrome DevTools,
which had the wonderful
stuff in the service workers.
So inside Chrome
DevTools, we actually
have a whole lot of HTTPS stuff.
And this is showing you, you
can look at the certificates.
You can look whether the site
has mixed content, which means
some secure and some insecure.
And it will show you
a whole lot of stuff
that you can debug with.
It'll put out
console log warnings.
So as a developer, when you're
trying to debug your site
and you don't know why you
haven't got the green lock,
the Chrome Developer
Tools will help you.
And I'm sure all the other
browsers pretty much have this.
So what's next, we have
basically a whole lot of stuff
that you can look at on the
developers.google.cn website.
So encrypting data in transit,
which just kind of explains
how this all works, using
content security policy--
does anyone know about content
security policy in here?
Put up your hands if you
know what [? cause ?] is?
Excellent, I would highly
recommend people read this
because this is very important.
Content security policy is
a way of enforcing loading
from third domains, like
other domains than your own.
And one of the nice things
you can do with the content
security policy
stuff is if you have
a site that is migrating,
on your server,
you can add a header
that will give you
a warning in the
console whenever you try
and load non-encrypted content.
So things like this, there
are some very good practices
that you can following
there and guidelines
for preventing mixed content.
So anyway, I have a nice
short talk for you today.
And I would just
highly recommend you
all switched HTTPS because,
as I said at the beginning,
I'll just reinforce it, the days
of e-commerce on the web here
today.
And it's huge.
And it's up to you to
protect your users,
protect the money that they're
paying to you for services,
and also protect your
own revenue streams
when you're running sites.
And if you want to a progressive
web app with service worker,
it's required.
So anyway, thanks for
listening to me today,
and hope you learned something.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: You said
searching ranking rule
is the common rule for almost
searcher like Baidu or Bing.
This is the common rule
recommend to use the link
the HTTPS domain, dot com.
ALEX DANILO: Yes, that was
the question of whether using
the link rel=canonical is the
right way for search engine
such as Baidu and
Bing, et cetera.
Yes, this is common knowledge
for all the search engines.
So that's the best practices
so that the algorithms that
generate the searching
database understand
that that is the definitive
version of your site.
Especially if, so if you have
a site that you're migrating,
like say that you already
had a site that was on HTTP,
and it has a ranking.
So that ranking is stored
against the URL with the HTTP
on the front.
As soon as you do the redirect
and then put the link,
rel=canonical, then the
search engine will assign all
the weights of the
ranking to the HTTPS site.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: May I ask you some
tips for mobile developer,
like Tinder?
It works for [INAUDIBLE]
or make the server notify
our [INAUDIBLE] work for HTTPS?
ALEX DANILO: Can you repeat
the question, please?
AUDIENCE: OK, I want to add
[INAUDIBLE] in my mobile apps
for HTTPS.
[INAUDIBLE]
ALEX DANILO: A pin?
Or--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ALEX DANILO: Oh, pinning?
AUDIENCE: It works for HTTPS?
It works for HTTPS?
ALEX DANILO: I'm not actually
sure of the answer to that,
sorry.
AUDIENCE: I think he's
asking your opinion
about like mobile development
on using HTTPS, maybe some tips,
maybe some like extra.
ALEX DANILO: Oh, tips.
My opinion, well HTTPS is,
for mobile, is basically
very little cost, in terms
of performance, battery life,
and things like that.
A long time ago, five years
ago, that was not the case.
But now in a modern
browser, the CPU load
for using HTTPS is like
less than 1% over HTTP,
it's a very low
computational cost.
And as far as
performance, latency
is, once the
connection is set up,
it's exactly the same as HTTP.
If you shift to HTTP/2, you will
see lower latency and higher
performance.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
Thanks, Thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: OK, let
me do a translation.
So you just mention HTTPS
together with HTTP/2
to give a performance boost
on mobile development.
But the question here is
that for Android development,
if we don't account
for HTTPS, well,
actually 2, what would be
your suggestion about HTTPS
in mobile development
because that seems
to incur a performance hit.
ALEX DANILO: Very good question.
In general, the performance
hit is very low.
The weather.com example,
their performance
hit that they took was
due to the architecture
of their application,
not HTTPS itself.
So basically the only cost
is in the initial set up,
if there is any cost.
And so if you do the
permanent redirect and the TLS
false start, you will
reduce the round tripping.
And so the performance
cost is almost negligible.
You wouldn't even notice it.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: I think
the question is,
for to be able to
get the certificate,
security is always
the first concern.
And you just mentioned
two wonderful places
to get the certificate.
Now the question
is, he's wondering
how secure, what was guaranteed
for security for those site
as they are open source, which
I'm not sure if it's correct.
So what's your opinion on that?
ALEX DANILO: OK, well firstly
to get the certificate issued,
you have to prove who you are.
Like I said, they are just a
certificate issuing authority.
So you have to first
prove to them that you
own the domain, et cetera.
Those certificates are signed
by a central authority,
and so there isn't that problem
as far as their authenticity.
But one thing that I
did forget to mention,
which I should mention, with
both those things, SSLMATE
and Let's Encrypt,
they also provide
command line tools,
which lets you update,
maintain your certificates so
that they will never expire.
So they handle all
the automatic updating
when the certificates expire.
And so by using their
tools, it basically
takes the development
burden down to zero,
once you've started
using them, that is.
AUDIENCE: So basically
you're saying
that's safe to use those
websites to get a certificate.
ALEX DANILO: Yes, absolutely.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have heard that
we can use HTTPS to defend
the man in the middle attack.
But when I try to
attack myself website,
I change it from HTTP to HTTPS.
I successed.
What's the right
way to use, what's
the right way to use
HTTPS to defend man
in the middle attack.
ALEX DANILO: All right,
what's the way, the best
way to use HTTPS to prevent
a man in the middle attack?
When you attacked
your own website,
did you use a self-signed
certificate or certificate
from an authority?
AUDIENCE: I install, I install
a software in my server.
And try to pull request to my
self website by use browser.
And then I try to--
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: I'll try my best.
OK,
OK, I can try it, I think.
Since I have the microphone,
so I was listening.
So, so I think that the audience
is asking a debugging question.
He was trying to set
up a hacker machine,
trying to hack his own
domain using HTTPS.
And he found some issues
that his hacking machine,
in the same local
network can actually
intercept the response from
server and then return a 404
to the client.
And then the client
actually get the 404.
I mean, the [INAUDIBLE] the
content itself is encrypted.
But since he is still be able to
manipulate [INAUDIBLE] response
in some way.
ALEX DANILO: Yeah, OK.
If you're on a local network,
if you're going through a proxy
or if you're going
through anything,
there is nothing that
HTTPS can do to stop
you breaking the network.
You can cut through the network
by doing almost anything.
But if you are trying to
set up an HTTPS session,
the first thing that
goes out is the domain
that you're trying
to connect to.
And the certificate
that comes back
from the server to the client
is signed with that domain.
So even if you can block
the requests going out,
you should never
get a response back.
Like you, if you're doing it
on your own local network,
like there are exceptions.
For example, when you are
debugging service worker
on the local network, on
local host, 127.0.0.1,
you can actually use a
service worker without HTTPS.
You can use HTTP local
host because it's
the local, trusted network.
And the client understands that.
But you should never be
able to have the connection
from the server back
to the client blocked,
unless that
certificate is valid.
So if you successfully set up an
HTTPS connection to your server
that you were
trying to hack, you
would have had to have
served the certificate, which
validates the domain that
you trying to connect to.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK, I think he's still
filling out the question.
And I think maybe
I should correct
the previous translation.
He was not on the local machine,
he's from the same LAN, the,
it's like in the
same LAN network
you're sharing probably the
same set of IP [INAUDIBLE].
It doesn't matter.
So his follow-up
question is, he somehow
continued to have
[INAUDIBLE] [? pollution, ?]
and you know, still
manipulated some way.
But I think it's very
specific, in which
I'm not sure I get it right.
So maybe you guys can--
ALEX DANILO: Well,
I think what we
should do is talk after the--
he can come over here and talk
to me after the talk,
because this will go on
for a long time.
And you can explain
in more detail.
OK?
AUDIENCE: Hi, sir.
If we apply HTTPS
into our website,
so government can now see
the data during connection.
So do you think
the authorities are
more likely to block
the [INAUDIBLE]
of the use of free
certificates in the future?
ALEX DANILO: I honestly don't
know the answer to that.
I think that it's
basically impossible
to tell the difference in
the certificate itself,
because that goes over the
encrypted connection anyway,
because the
certificate is signed.
Because what happens in a--
that's basically like a
public/private key setup,
where the browser is
sending a public key.
The certificate gets encrypted.
And it comes back encrypted.
So there's no way to
know the issuer until it
decrypts on the client, anyway.
So that is not something
that's detectable.
So the data is not visible.
So, because the connection is
from the client to the server,
and encrypted in
both directions.
So the visibility of the
certificate authority
is nowhere to be seen
until it decrypts it
on the client in the browser.
So it should be no different
to any other certificate
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: How to debug?
ALEX DANILO: How
to debug the HTTPS
connection, or the handshake?
AUDIENCE: He was asking you
how the debug a binary data,
like web socket
things like that.
I mean using HTTPS, if he's
just putting binary data,
I'm not sure.
So it's how to debug binary data
including a web socket and some
of the things.
ALEX DANILO: Right,
you mean for like,
watching it to try
and work out what's
going back and forth
across the web socket?
AUDIENCE: Right, what kind
of tool you can use to debug,
say a binary data, or HTTPS?
ALEX DANILO: Or encrypted data?
Well, that's a
very hard question.
If you're talking about when
you're developing your site,
if you want to debug what's
going across the web socket,
I would--
It's a very hard question.
I'm not sure of the answer
to that, to be honest.
But maybe you can describe your
scenario to me after the talk
and we can talk through
it, because right now I
can't think of an answer.
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK one more question.
AUDIENCE: OK, so the
whole HTTPS story
is based on the certificate.
What happen if the local
copy of the certificate
was replaced by
a malicious copy?
ALEX DANILO: Then
you're in bad trouble.
Yeah, that's a very good,
very, very good question.
The certificates, because of
the way that they're encoded,
they remain encrypted
on the device.
So basically, if you have
some kind of malware thing
that compromise the certificate,
yes, there could be problems.
But again, this is kind
of beyond my expertise
in cryptography.
I know that there have been a
number of accidental collision
attacks, where people have been
able to generate certificates
that have the same hash
as another certificate.
And what we've done in
the browser community
is try to deprecate and get
rid of insecure, cryptographic
algorithms.
So for example, SHA-1, which
was used for certificates,
is something that is no
longer supported in browsers.
So Firefox, Edge, Chrome, all
don't honor that certificate,
because it's something
that we know can be broken.
So browsers have moved to
more secure, cryptographic
algorithms.
And so the chances
of impersonating
a valid certificate
are very, very low,
because those impersonations,
to replace a certificate
with another one
that impersonates,
means that you have
to have a collision
in the cryptographic hash, which
is very, very difficult to do.
So when we have identified
weaker encryptions,
they've been removed
from the browsers.
And so you will get the red bad
certificate icon on the address
bar, if that happens.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks, Alex.
ALEX DANILO: Thank
you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]